covering her mouth we're gonna kidnap
her is not gonna make her less scared
okay
Darla it's me it's Billy I know I don't
look like me a wizard made me look like
a wizard more confused
some old guy brought me to a temple and
he made me say Shazam where's that
probably triggered body manipulation
properties you can switch my sake Shazam
maybe what's that you are you okay I was
screwing a bulb
Darla you cannot tell anybody about this
all right it's Billy he's a hero but a
super villain finds out that either hero
that endangers us okay
heroes loved ones are like the perfect
bad guy target she even go to keep you
secrets mommy no oh God we're all foster
kids here all hands on deck give this
place a chance people can surprise you
sometimes
Bailey Benson Locker greatest power
[Music]
you're him Rosie right here the hero
if superhero can't save his family it's
not much para pg-13 II see it early with
Fandango hi everyone its charlie there's
a whole bunch of new Shazam footage to
break down we got more details about
what's going on with the Black Adam
movie and there's a bunch of Shazam
stuff happening this weekend that I'll
explain if you're brand new to the
channel I do DC videos every week be
sure to subscribe to get everything
we're also doing an IMAX ticket giveaway
because there's so many big movies
coming out in the next couple of months
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and just leave a comment
about why you're super hyped up about
Shazam on the video the clips pick up
right after Billy gets his powers he has
no idea what's going on the wizard
doesn't give him a tutorial or and
explain or anything so he freaks out -
Freddie they have the montage of them
testing their powers then they come back
home but he still doesn't know how the
power word works how he can activate and
deactivate his powers just by saying the
word Shazam
so Darla finds out the voice in the
hallway that says what happened to the
staircase is Mary Marvel who shows up
later in the footage then they try to
sneak back out without Darla telling
everyone else how do you keepin secrets
I'm kind of good no she's terrible she
will definitely not keep this secret the
other part of the promo is just hyping
up - Shazam family of it all like you
have this foster family and you have the
human child Billy there's trying to
learn to be a part of that and trust
people but on the other side of that you
have the supernatural Shazam family
aspect of it so the film is full of all
kinds of Easter eggs I know people are
asking all kinds of questions about
Easter eggs for the classic Shazam
comics like deep cuts from when he was
still called Captain Marvel things like
Tony the Tiger the film does have enough
Easter eggs and references to DC and
Shazam comic book specific things that
it is worth it to go see it more than
once in the theater I mean it's not
nearly as big as say like Avengers
endgame which Marvel is now hyping up to
be the biggest thing they've ever done
in the history of the studio that will
not be equaled until they close down
their next saga of Avengers films but I
think everybody has an idea for how big
this movie is going to be it's much
smaller than one of those big huge
crossover films because it's just the
Shazam and Shazam family characters not
including Black Adam they've actually
been dropping a lot more footage
recently so if they have any like really
cool clips then I'll do videos for that
mostly Superman Batman familiar Justice
League references you may have also
picked up on the slide dig at Superman
during this promo but he says if a
superhero can't say
his family he's not much of a superhero
he just straight-up made teenage
Superman cry watching paw can't die in
that tornado
they really do lean into the stranger
things sort of Spielberg II and aspect
of it where you have a bunch of kids
trying to solve a problem together even
though most of the promos have been
selling this as Billy versus dr. sivana
with a lot of Freddy on the side trying
to help him learn his abilities but the
family is a big part of the actual story
of the film it just doesn't quite come
across and the trailers they've been
posting there isn't made credits and a
post credit scene so be sure to stay
through the entire credits and we have
learned a little bit about what's going
on with the Black Adam film like
supposedly atom smasher Hawkman and even
star girl is supposed to be in it of all
people I know that sounds kind of weird
because Hawkman definitely sounds like a
really hardcore character that would be
in a black atom though my guess is they
would want star girl in it to balance
the tone out a little bit but atom
smasher in the comics was a good friend
to Black Adam during the Justice Society
run because a long time ago he did work
with the Justice Society for a little
while but it's been a long time since
that comic book arc so that's why a lot
of people and a lot of outlets are
saying that the movie is actually going
to be based on the comic book storyline
Black Adam the Dark Age it's only a
six-issue run it's actually pretty small
and I would assume that they would
change a couple big plot points because
they'd have to explain where Black Adam
has been this whole time and that story
comes after a really big run in that he
has with Billy Batson Shazam who takes
his powers away effectively all Billy
has to do is change the word the Black
Adam has to say in order to activate his
powers but he doesn't tell Black Adam
what the word is so Black Adam is
effectively powerless for most of the
run but it also came after his great
loves already Tomasz whose name I can't
say out loud because YouTube will flag
the video because apparently it's the
word of a terrorist organization she had
just been killed off during World War 3
during a different comic book arc so
he's all pissed off he doesn't have any
of his powers so the story of Black Adam
the Dark Age is him going on a quest to
1 get his powers back find out what the
word is that will activate his powers
and restore his great love back to life
so it's a little bit of a heist film
it's a little bit of him ducking the
Justice Society because they are trying
to capture him and throw him in prison
he doesn't have his powers so it's much
easier for them to apprehend him
everyone in the world wants a piece of
him so he has to slip his way past the
border guard back into con dog
to get the remains of his re Tomasz take
her bones to a Lazarus Pit try to
resurrect her that way that doesn't
quite work he has to use her jewel and
call upon her power word to sort of
temporarily give himself powers but that
drains life from her the more he sucks
the life out of his re tome as he even
does that to one of his friends - I mean
it's a super hardcore story he winds up
eating his friend to survive while he's
hiking his way to a Lazarus Pit
hilariously he accidentally finds out
what his new power word is that Billy
changed it to true to form Billy changed
it to big chocolate egg creams which is
basically a milkshake within the DC
universe so black Adam chuckles thinking
that his new power word is chocolate
milkshake ah Billy Oh is the child
he's almost successful but he's working
with Felix Faust who double-crosses them
and tricks him into thinking that the
process of bringing zari Tomasz back to
life did not work so he goes away super
pissed off thinking that he's failed
Felix Faust secretly uses the bones of
elongated man if you're a big flash TV
show fan elongated man as a character on
there right now he'd been dead for a
little while so he secretly uses his
bones to trick Black Adam after Black
Adam flies off in a rage he conducts the
ceremony doing it the correct way
bringing her back to life with her full
powers and uses her to escape his
magical prison inside the Tower of dr.
fate so then it spins off into another
big comic book arc so effectively the
Dark Age is a very dark story about him
trying to get his powers back which he's
successful at but he's also trying to
bring his wife back to life which he is
unsuccessful at which you know
ultimately on the path to that he does a
lot of really terrible things it's more
of an antihero type story so if you
remember some of the storylines or some
of the movies that you may have seen the
rock in where he plays a not so nice guy
but they try to give him a motivation
that makes him seem less Despicable even
though he does a lot of really bad
things
if you fashion yourself a connoisseur of
the rocks films the Scorpion King is
probably a good example of that where he
starts out as a relatively good
character with good intentions and
slowly circles the drain and eventually
does some really really terrible stuff
in wines of succumbing to darkness all
I'm really hoping for from the Black
Adam film is that they just established
him as a really cool badass antihero
within the DC Universe and then they
could just use him in whatever other big
films that they want to if they're not
going to do a ton of black Adam solo
films even though DC films aren't
supposed to be quite as
Terk connected as they were before
they'll still be minor crossover I think
that the rocks version of Black Adam
would be great in a Suicide Squad sequel
if the James Gunn's Suicide Squad
franchise takes off he's rebooting that
so it's not gonna be Suicide Squad - I
think the working title right now is the
Suicide Squad I think that you know
that'd be great franchise for recurring
backup DC villains like Black Manta is
supposedly gonna float around to a
couple different DC films outside of the
Aquaman solo film if they play their
cards right there'll be a whole bunch of
b-list characters that can just hop
around all over the place hopefully
that'll be an easy way to develop a lot
of really good villains if they want to
do a future Justice League movie versus
the injustice league or something like
that they kind of tease that at the end
of the last Justice League movie but
there's this soft reboot of the universe
that's going on so by the time they're
actually ready to do another Justice
League film things will probably look
quite a bit different really good news
is I'm allowed to post my non-spoilery
Shazam review tomorrow my spoiler e1
will post a little bit closer when the
movie comes out that's also when I'll do
my Easter eggs and post credit scene
videos same video schedule for all the
other big movies that I do videos for so
if you have big questions about the
movies or the comics or anything at all
or any videos that you want to request
just let me know in the comments below
congratulations hold duck your the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
guess who's coming to the next episode
of the flash it's titled Godspeed you
can click here for that trailer and
click here for all my brand new Avengers
endgame trailer Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]